[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Ja, die Ferien sind schon da, die Sommerferien.
Lang ersehnt!
Die Kinder waren ja eigentlich lange genug zu Hause,
aber egal, sie haben jetzt Sommerferien.
Und dann kommt wieder die Einschulung.
Und wie jedes Jahr gibt es natürlich auf meinem Kanal
eine Einschulungstorte!
Die aus den letzten Jahren könnt ihr euch natürlich anschauen.
Ich habe jetzt Besuch bekommen gestern.
Unser Freund ist da, der Philip.
Man sieht es eben.
Man sieht es, glaube ich, schon, wer da ist.
Philip, komm rein! Komm!
Und der Philip hat uns so viele Süßigkeiten mitgebracht!
>> PHILIP: Hello!
Hallo!
Hach!
Schön, da
>> SALLY: Und dann
>> PHILIP: zu sein.
>> SALLY: saßen wir auf der Terrasse.
Dann zeigt er mir diese Box:
"Back to the 90s".
Und ich meine, wir zwei sind ja Kinder der Neunziger.
>> PHILIP: Aber hallo!
>> SALLY: Nicht in den Neunzigern geboren,
aber in den Neunzigern aufgewachsen.
>> PHILIP: Richtig.
Und ja, groß geworden.
>> SALLY: Ach, komm. Wir können auch sagen,
wir sind 90 geboren.
>> PHILIP: Ah, die 90s! Ja.
>> SALLY: Egal, dann sind wir jetzt halt...
Dann wäre ich ja 30.
Ich bin 91 geboren.
>> PHILIP: Ja.
>> SALLY: So.
Ich bin 91 geboren
und nächstes Jahr bin ich dann 92 geboren.
>> PHILIP: Golden 30.
>> SALLY: Kinder der Neunziger.
>> PHILIP: Ja.
>> SALLY: Also hier weiß ich ja schon, was drin ist.
Und mir kam eben die Idee,
ich mache eine Einschulungstorte,
so eine Schultüte.
Ich habe schon mal eine Schultüte gemacht,
aber egal, ich mache noch mal eine, eine neue.
Und dann mache ich so Candys, die so rauskommen.
>> PHILIP: Candy, alles rein. Ja.
>> SALLY: Weil, ganz ehrlich, in meiner Schultüte
waren auch viele Süßigkeiten.
>> PHILIP: Ja, ist ja auch eine Schultüte.
>> SALLY: Gehört auch dazu.
>> PHILIP: Das wollte ich gerade sagen.
>> SALLY: Hier habe ich alle Süßigkeiten
und die packen wir später rein.
>> PHILIP: Alle da rein.
Ufos sind natürlich auch cool.
Guck mal. Ich glaube, die sind hier.
>> SALLY: Okay. Die habe ich schon aufgemacht.
>> PHILIP: Ah!
Also ich glaube,
– guck mal –
der klassische Schultütenartikel.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> PHILIP: Die kennen auch alle.
>> SALLY: Und da kann ich eine Tüte komplett selber essen.
>> PHILIP: Die mit rein. Genau.
>> SALLY: Okay. >> PHILIP: Genau.
>> SALLY: Und jetzt packe ich die Box aus.
>> PHILIP: Uh!
>> SALLY: Ist das so eine Limited Edition oder so?
>> PHILIP: Ja, was ganz, also wirklich Besonderes
nur dieses Jahr.
Weil wir haben ja sozusagen jetzt Bubble Gum gelauncht.
Das hast du ja eben schon gezeigt.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> PHILIP: Weil das ist wirklich die Neunziger.
Die sind einfach so cool.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> PHILIP: Sie machen immer Spaß.
>> SALLY: Oh, Bubble-Gum-Geschmack! Mein Gott!
>> PHILIP: Und genau, als Kaubonbon.
Und deshalb gibt es so eine Limited-Edition-Box.
Ja, eine habe ich dir mitgebracht.
>> SALLY: Ach, nein!
"Liebe Sally, wir feiern die Neunzigerjahre weiter
und das am liebsten mit dir zusammen."
Und das Ganze auf einem Diddl-Block!
Nein, wie cool!
Okay, ich sehe schon die
>> SALLY & PHILIP: Bubble Gum.
>> SALLY: Die sind so lecker!
Eine Maske.
>> PHILIP: Eine Gesichtsmaske. Ja.
>> SALLY: Cool!
Aber das mache ich dann heute Abend.
O mein Gott!
Ich hatte noch nie eine Bauchtasche.
>> PHILIP: Die kannst du so richtig chic runterhängen
>> SALLY: O mein Gott!
>> PHILIP: jetzt wie...
>> SALLY: Früher hat man sie doch so am Bauch getragen.
>> PHILIP: Genau. Und jetzt aber...
>> SALLY: So, nicht? >> PHILIP: Ja.
>> SALLY: Das war so 90.
Und jetzt trägt man sie so.
>> PHILIP: So. Ja.
>> SALLY: Warte. Wie trägt sie der Sturmi immer?
So.
O mein Gott! Ein Lippenstift!
Gleich mal auschecken.
Ach, wie cool!
Oh!
>> SALLY & PHILIP: Oh!
>> PHILIP: Und?
>> SALLY: Okay. Komm, das mache ich mir gleich drauf.
Oh, UNO!
>> PHILIP: Für die ganze Family.
>> SALLY: O mein Gott!
>> PHILIP: Da können wir nachher mal spielen.
>> SALLY: Können wir später spielen.
>> PHILIP: Ja, wollte ich gerade sagen.
>> SALLY: Wir zocken Murat ab.
Ich zocke Murat
– ich muss ihn abzocken!
Ach, nein!
Das sind doch die, die musste man sich dann so...
Warte.
>> PHILIP: In die...
>> SALLY: Warte.
So.
>> PHILIP: Das passt mit deiner Frise jetzt ganz gut.
>> SALLY: Und dann so richtig so Cyndi-Lauper-mäßig.
>> PHILIP: In die Haare.
>> SALLY: So.
So richtig so einen hohen Pferdeschwanz.
>> PHILIP: Sitzt.
>> SALLY: Sitzt es so?
Oh, yes!
>> PHILIP: Kreolen natürlich.
>> SALLY: Kreolen.
>> PHILIP: Da kommt eins zum anderen.
>> SALLY: Ja, komm, warte.
Jetzt, wenn schon, dann richtig, oder?
>> PHILIP: Jetzt geht es los!
>> SALLY: Jetzt machen wir hier gleich die 90s-Party.
Oh, wow, wow!
>> PHILIP: Wow!
>> SALLY: Cool!
>> PHILIP: Eine Kette?
>> SALLY: Ja!
>> PHILIP: Hei!
>> SALLY: Mannomann!
Ich glaube, das ist...
Ist das für den Arm? Wahrscheinlich, nicht?
>> PHILIP: Wenn man sie zweimal drumlegt.
>> SALLY: Hm.
Mega!
Okay. Jetzt muss ich aber noch den Lippenstift.
Komm, den mache ich noch kurz.
>> PHILIP: Ach, da ist der Spiegel!
Okay.
>> SALLY: Der Kenwood-Spiegel.
>> PHILIP: Das geht gut!
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Wir sind die Kinder
>> SALLY & PHILIP: der Neunziger!
>> PHILIP: Können hier mal alle mitsingen?
>> PHILIP: Also wir können es nicht lesen.
Ihr dürft singen.
>> PHILIP: So
>> SALLY & PHILIP: I'll tell you what I want, what I really, really want.
So tell me what you want, what you really, really want.
I wanna, h, I wanna, h, I wanna, h, I wanna, h,
I wanna really, really, really wanna zigazig ah!
>> SALLY: If you want my future,
>> PHILIP: Genau. Für die Hitschies.
>> SALLY: forget my past!
Das ist ja cool!
>> PHILIP: Geil, nicht?
Ja. Also...
>> SALLY: Oh, danke, Philip! Danke, danke, danke!
>> PHILIP: Sehr, sehr gerne!
Richtig cool!
>> SALLY: Weißt du was? Dann chill du mal mit dem Murat.
>> PHILIP: Ich gehe mal mit dem Murat
ein bisschen Strumpfhosen ausprobieren, chillen,
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> PHILIP: ein paar Hitschies futtern.
>> SALLY: Ja, die würde ich jetzt auch noch anziehen
aber heute ist es zu warm.
>> PHILIP: Viel Spaß beim Backen!
>> SALLY: Danke!
>> PHILIP: Tschü!
>> SALLY: Und wir sehen uns später
und dann dekorieren wir zusammen.
>> PHILIP: Tschü! Tschü! Das machen wir!
>> SALLY: Los geht es also mit der Torte.
Ich habe mir gedacht,
ich backe jetzt einfach einen Blechkuchen.
Und da habe ich das Grundrezept von meinem Blog
und in der App genommen
und zwar den Mandelrührkuchen.
Ich habe dafür die Eier mit dem Zucker,
Salz und Vanilleextrakt richtig schön schaumig gerührt.
Dann kommt etwas Buttermilch mit Öl dazu.
Dann gemahlene Mandeln mit Mehl und Backpulver.
Und fertig ist schon der Rührkuchen.
Der wird dann direkt in den Backrahmen eingegossen
und dann eben im Ofen gebacken.
Den Kuchen habe ich jetzt hier bereits rausgeholt.
Also die ganz ausführlichen Schritte
könnt ihr euch gerne im Grundrezept anschauen.
Der Kuchen ist jetzt auch schon schön abgekühlt.
Ich stelle ihn jetzt aber schon, weil er abgekühlt ist,
noch in den Kühlschrank oder ins Gefrierfach.
So lässt er sich gleich besser schneiden.
Und ich habe mir gedacht,
ich probiere heute mal was Neues aus
und zwar eine Buttercreme
zum Anrühren.
Da gebe ich nämlich nur Wasser und Butter dazu.
Falls ihr eine Buttercreme selber machen wollt,
könnt ihr zum Beispiel die italienische
oder die Swiss Meringue Buttercream machen.
Da gibt es auch schon Rezepte auf meinem Kanal,
Grundrezepte.
Ihr könnt die Torte aber auch mit Ganache füllen.
Das ist eine Creme aus Schokolade und Sahne.
Da gibt es auch schon ein Grundrezept.
Also entscheidet einfach selbst,
wie ihr die Torte füllen möchtet.
Ich mache das hier heute so.
Und bei der Buttercreme ist es so:
Da nehme ich den Beutelinhalt
und verrühre ihn mit Wasser.
Ich mache jetzt mal die doppelte Menge,
weil ich noch nicht so genau weiß,
wie groß die Torte wird.
Aber ich schreibe euch dann
in den Blog natürlich und ins Rezept,
wie viel Menge ich gebraucht habe.
Aber lieber habe ich ein bisschen zu viel da als zu wenig.
Die Butter habe ich bereits zimmerwarm.
Die brauche ich aber erst später.
Und ich kann jetzt hier alles mit Wasser verrühren.
Riecht sehr gut nach Vanille.
[Musik]
Also kurz glatt rühren.
Jetzt decke ich es ab
und lasse es 30 Minuten stehen
und rühre danach einfach noch die weiche Butter ein.
Das war es erst mal.
Und weiter geht es mit der Buttercreme.
Also, wie gesagt, ich probiere die zum ersten Mal.
Ich habe jetzt hier die weiche Butter,
gebe da das dazu
und dann wird das Ganze für zehn Minuten schaumig gerührt
oder cremig gerührt,
bis es eine tolle Konsistenz hat
und schmeckt.
Und ich nehme jetzt den Schneebesenaufsatz,
weil die Butter wirklich schon schön weich ist.
[Musik]
Die Buttercreme ist fertig.
Hier habe ich den Kuchen. Der ist schon abgekühlt.
Und jetzt ist mir eingefallen
– inspiriert von der 90s-Box, mache ich jetzt Folgendes.
Ich nehme jetzt die Hitschies,
die Bubble Gum.
Die sind schon gut.
Und die werde ich als Füllung noch reinmachen.
Nicht nur Deko, sondern Füllung.
Wow!
Okay. Das heißt,
die hacke ich jetzt so ein bisschen.
Ich glaube, das wird cool.
Weil dann habe ich diesen Bubble-Gum-Geschmack
nämlich in der Torte.
[Musik]
Aber jetzt geht es erst einmal
an die Torte.
Aus dieser eckigen Platte mache ich jetzt eine Schultüte.
Es fragt sich noch wie,
aber ich mache das jetzt erst mal so.
Ich drittle die jetzt einfach mal.
Manchmal habe ich vorher noch keinen Plan
und dann wird es einfach.
Dann kommt hier Füllung rein
Die Buttercreme, die lasse ich jetzt auch so geschmacklich.
[Musik]
Da kommen jetzt die Hitschies drauf.
So.
Dann hier die Platte drauf
Und dann one more time.
[Musik]
Die Füllung ist schon mal fertig.
Jetzt den Deckel drauf.
Und jetzt darf die Torte erst mal in die Kühlung.
Hier noch ein bisschen glatt streichen.
Denn ich schneide ja da gleich die Schultüte zu.
Die Creme stelle ich auch kurz in den Kühlschrank,
weil es hier in der Küche sehr warm ist.
Und dann kann ich in der Zwischenzeit
aber schon mal ein bisschen Deko vorbereiten.
Denn die Schultüte, die braucht ja auch Dekoration.
[Musik]
Hier knete ich jetzt einfach ein paar Farben Fondant.
Also ich habe jetzt hier Rosa.
Da brauche ich nichts reinmischen.
Lila und Weiß vermische ich ein bisschen
für ein helleres Lila.
Grün und Weiß vermische ich.
Und dann brauche ich einfach noch Gelb und Hellblau.
[Musik]
Ich glaube, das sind echt so die richtigen Farben
für so eine 90s-Torte.
Jetzt kann ich den Fondant mit Bäckerstärke ausrollen.
Ich brauche ja eigentlich echt immer nur so ein bisschen.
So ganz dünn ausrollen.
Und das geht mit dem auch echt gut.
Da ist nämlich Sheabutter drin statt Palmfett,
also wirklich hochwertiges Fett,
und dadurch ist der Fondant elastischer
und reißt nicht so schnell.
So.
Ich rolle jetzt erst mal alle so ein bisschen aus.
Und, was ich dann nicht brauche, verpacke ich gleich luftdicht,
damit es eben nicht trocknet.
Und ihr könnt ja jetzt, wenn ihr sagt:
"Ich möchte eine andere Schultüte machen, keine 90s,
sondern aus diesem Jahrhundert und aus der jetzigen Zeit",
dann gestaltet sie einfach so, wie ihr möchtet.
[Musik]
Und jetzt machen wir noch so typische Muster,
also zum einen natürlich Kreise.
Und da machen wir es jetzt auch so:
Schaut mal. Ich nehme jetzt einfach so eine Spritztülle.
Ich habe eine größere und kleinere.
Und dann
kann man daraus nämlich Ringe ausstechen.
[Musik]
Und dann das Gleiche noch mal mit einer anderen Farbe.
Und so wird das dann später so dieses coole Muster.
Und dann mache ich noch ein paar Dreiecke und Vierecke.
Und dann haben wir es, glaube ich.
[Musik]
Hm.
So sieht es gut aus.
Jetzt habe ich hier eine Schablone und gucke mal,
wie ich jetzt am besten die Torte schneide.
Ich glaube, ich mache das so.
Einfach so den einfachsten Winkel nehmen.
Und dann
hier dransetzen
und so schneiden.
Da guckt ihr einfach, wie groß eure Torte sein soll.
Und hier vorne diesen Beutel, den schneide ich jetzt so mit,
also diese Rundung.
Perfekt!
Jetzt nehme ich ein bisschen von der Buttercreme
und klebe die Torte hier an.
Und dann wird die Torte
– ihr könnt sie entweder so lassen
oder schon ein bisschen 3D machen.
Und ich finde es immer schön, wenn sie wirklich 3D wird,
wenn auch nur leicht.
Und ich finde, von der Größe her ist sie jetzt wirklich super,
sodass ich sagen muss,
nicht zu viel, nicht zu wenig.
Und die Reste könnt ihr dann noch nehmen
und hier oben noch ein bisschen aufbauen,
dass sie einfach eine schöne Rundung bekommt.
Und da müsst ihr euch einfach
so ein bisschen nach Gefühl vorantasten
und immer wieder Creme nehmen,
Messer ansetzen, ein bisschen was wegschneiden.
Und hier unten auch so ein bisschen
unter den Boden schneiden,
damit die Rundung schon noch ein bisschen weitergeht.
Ich glaube so langsam,
die einfache Menge an Buttercreme hätte doch gereicht.
Aber gut. Ich wollte lieber ein bisschen zu viel dahaben.
Wobei ich...
Ich bin ja auch blöd. Weil, ich meine,
man kann die ja einfach ganz schnell anrühren.
Na ja, egal.
Deswegen teste ich es ja für euch vor.
Und ihr könnt sie dann nachmachen
mit den richtigen Mengenverhältnissen.
So. Jetzt schön einstreichen mit der kompletten Creme.
Die ist nämlich auch fondanttauglich.
Das ist perfekt.
Das heißt, wenn man echt mal ganz schnell
so eine Motivtorte machen will,
Buttercreme kurz anrühren,
nach Belieben auch geschmacklich verfeinern,
mit Sirup, mit Aromen, mit Zitronenschale, Vanille,
– wobei, vanillig schmeckt sie schon,
also richtig gut –
einfärben und dann geht das Backen und Dekorieren
echt rucki, zucki schnell.
Und ich streiche die jetzt hier schön ein,
stelle sie wieder ins Gefrierfach, damit sie fest wird,
und dann kommt noch mal so Topcoating drauf,
also wirklich noch mal so die letzte schöne, glatte Schicht.
Und dann geht es schon an die Deko.
[Musik]
Jetzt kurz kühlen
und dann, wie gesagt, noch mal schön glatt streichen.
Aber so geht das echt ruck, zuck und ganz schnell.
Und vor allem ist ganz gut,
denn man hat so ein Stückchen
zum direkt Naschen.
Boah!
Schmeckt toll!
[Musik]
Jetzt habe ich hier hellblauen Fondant.
Damit überziehe ich jetzt die Torte.
Also wird die Schultüte bei mir hellblau.
[Musik]
Und dann schön glatt streichen.
Das ist jetzt echt auch so eine schöne Größe.
Also für so eine kleine, feine Familienfeier zur Einschulung
passt die Torte perfekt.
So. Jetzt die Reste hier außen wegschneiden
und so ein bisschen drunterschieben.
Dann hat man so ein bisschen das Ganze dreidimensionaler.
[Musik]
So.
Die Spitze einfach weggeschnitten.
Und da vorne kann ich den Überrest auch wegschneiden.
Denn da kommt ja noch die andere Farbe hin.
[Musik]
Und da nehme ich jetzt einfach die Rückseite.
Da passt die Torte perfekt drauf.
Und da lege ich jetzt die Masse drauf.
Und das ist dann die Tafel
und da liegt dann die Schultüte drauf.
Ja.
So mache ich das.
[Musik]
Dann
auf den Ausrollstab
aufrollen.
Dann nehme ich mein Tablett.
Ja, ist ja alles essbar.
Von daher...
Ich gebe jetzt hier halt essbaren Kleber drauf.
Und das kann man ja später alles wieder wegwaschen.
So.
Und jetzt...
Oh!
Aber das ist gar nicht schlimm.
Denn der Fondant
ist ja elastisch.
Und ich habe jetzt hier so einen Rand
und kann mich da entlang hangeln
und einfach schön glatt wegschneiden.
So.
Schon haben wir eine Tafel.
Liebe Schulen,
wenn ihr keine Tafel mehr habt,
backt euch eine!
Da kommt jetzt die Torte drauf.
Und jetzt wirklich oben schön Platz lassen,
so,
damit die ganzen Süßigkeiten noch Platz haben.
Und jetzt klebe ich hier die ganze Deko drauf.
Die Namen habe ich jetzt noch ausgestochen.
Und die Deko einfach mit essbarem Kleber aufkleben.
[Musik]
Hier habe ich jetzt ein bisschen grünen Fondant
mit Blütenpaste gemischt.
Fondant an sich härtet ja jetzt nicht so aus.
Das heißt, der bleibt immer schön
auf der Tortenoberfläche weich für den Anschnitt.
Und Blütenpaste,
daraus kann man ganz filigrane Sachen formen
und die härtet wirklich gut aus.
Wenn man beides eins zu eins mischt,
hat man eine Modelliermasse, die gut aushärtet
und die eben auch schön in Form bleibt.
Und damit mache ich jetzt gleich dieses Krepppapier.
Denn zu unserer Zeit waren die Schultüten
oben so mit Krepppapier
oder auch mit Stoff sogar.
Schön dünn.
Und ich möchte diese Krepppapier
jetzt noch ein bisschen strukturieren.
Und ihr kennt ja vielleicht schon
diese Stempel, diese Prägestempel.
Die könnt ihr zum Beispiel benutzen bei so einer Steinoptik.
Die wäre einfach für die Harry-Potter-Torte perfekt gewesen.
Hier hat man so ein Korbgeflecht
und hier noch so andere Muster mit so Miniherzchen,
mit so kleinen Kreuzchen.
Und die nehme ich jetzt
und drücke das hier einfach vorsichtig rein.
Oh ja!
Das sieht cool aus!
[Musik]
Oh, das sieht cool aus!
Guckt einmal!
Zicke, zacke, zicke, zacke.
Da-da-da-dam!
Gut. Dann hole ich doch jetzt mal die Torte und wir dekorieren.
>> PHILIP: Können wir?
Okay, also kurze Frage. Und zwar...
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> PHILIP: Saure Drachenzungen.
>> PHILIP: Saure Spinnenbeine. Okay?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> PHILIP: Total coole Artikel,
machen echt Spaß, sind schön sauer.
Und dann auch ein richtig cooler Artikel.
Aber der Name "Volles Rohr",
der passt halt nicht so ganz.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> PHILIP: Jetzt ist die Frage an euch:
Wie nennen wir den Artikel?
Also das ist praktisch sauer
und innen drin so ein Fondantteig, Vanilleteig.
>> SALLY: Mmh!
>> PHILIP: Jetzt müssen wir uns da irgendwie mal
einen Namen überlegen, wie wir die nennen.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> PHILIP: Das sind die leckersten.
>> SALLY: Ha! Und ich nehme jetzt den?
>> PHILIP: Ja, gut.
>> SALLY: Mmh!
Mmh! Ich liebe sauer!
>> PHILIP: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Mmh!
>> PHILIP: Aber da brauchen...
Also ja, also da müssen wir einen Namen...
Weil der Drachen
– Volles Rohr ist da noch nicht...
>> SALLY: Aber komm, lass uns doch die Community fragen.
Und dann machen wir ein Gewinnspiel daraus.
>> PHILIP: Ja, aber eine gute Idee!
>> SALLY: Und was verlosen wir?
Wir schauen in die Kommentare
und wer einen Kommentar abgibt mit dem coolsten Namen,
der dann ausgesucht wird von Philip,
der bekommt eine Hitschie-Box.
>> PHILIP: Ja.
Also seid kreativ!
Viel Spaß!
>> SALLY: So. Das war jetzt aber spontan!
>> PHILIP: Das war eher so mal ganz spontan!
Nummer eins. So.
>> SALLY: So, einfach mal Hitschies rausgehauen.
>> PHILIP: Jetzt legen wir los mit der Deko.
>> SALLY: Okay. Guck mal.
Ich habe mir jetzt gedacht, das ist ja jetzt die Tafel.
Ich habe hier weiße Lebensmittelfarbe verdünnt
>> PHILIP: Okay.
>> SALLY: und schreibe jetzt erst mal was auf die Tafel,
so "Zur Einschulung" vielleicht.
>> PHILIP: 1 + 1 = 3.
>> SALLY: Ja, oben so "Zur Einschulung",
unten so "1 + 1 = 3".
Und alle Kinder so: "Das stimmt nicht!"
>> PHILIP: So. Und dann machen wir noch mal die 1. Klasse.
>> SALLY: Das sieht nämlich dann aus wie Tafel.
Wow!
[Musik]
Wie machen wir das jetzt?
Also eigentlich woll-
Also eine geschlossene Schultüte sieht, glaube ich, cool aus,
aber ich glaub, eine offene
>> PHILIP: Eine offene!
>> SALLY: sieht noch cooler aus.
>> PHILIP: Die Ufos fliegen im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes raus.
>> SALLY: Wir machen
– oh, ich müsste die Torte kurz anheben.
>> PHILIP: Soll ich so einen – haben wir so einen Heber?
>> SALLY: Hm. Ja, so ein Tortendingsda.
Okay. Dann hier
– kannst du das da mit drunterschieben?
>> PHILIP: Ja, klar.
>> SALLY: Und los!
>> PHILIP: Eins, zwei.
Ein bisschen höher noch.
Ja, passt.
>> SALLY: Noch ein bisschen hier.
So. Perfekt!
>> PHILIP: Okay.
>> SALLY: Voll gut!
Also ich würde sagen,
wir packen jetzt hier die ganzen Süßigkeiten rein.
>> PHILIP: Ja.
>> SALLY: Eigentlich ist ja geschlossene Tüte ganz schön,
aber wir lassen sie offen.
Aber
eine Info habe ich jetzt noch, die, glaube ich, ganz wichtig ist.
>> PHILIP: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und zwar ist ja oft immer das Problem,
dass man in Produkten Schweinegelatine hat.
>> PHILIP: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und dann nehmen es viele nicht,
Veganer nicht, Muslime nicht,
>> PHILIP: Richtig.
>> SALLY: egal wer.
Und dann habt ihr ja – gerade die Hitschies –
>> PHILIP: Die Lösung.
>> SALLY: die Lösung.
Ihr habt ja Gelatine drin, aber es ist Rindergelatine
und die ist sogar halal.
>> PHILIP: Korrekt. Richtig.
>> SALLY: Halal, koscher.
>> PHILIP: Genau.
>> SALLY: Also das vielleicht zur Info.
Steht das auch drauf, halal?
>> PHILIP: Ja, halal unten.
Genau, da ist einmal das Halal-Zeichen.
>> SALLY: Ah, genau.
>> PHILIP: Aber da hatte der Murat gestern einen guten Tipp.
Wir schreiben jetzt auch "halal" drauf.
>> SALLY: Genau, weil, ganz ehrlich,
>> PHILIP: Unten ist es in Arabisch.
>> SALLY: ich kann zwar Arabisch als Koranschrift lesen,
>> PHILIP: Genau.
>> SALLY: aber das hätte ich jetzt nicht lesen können,
weil da die...
>> PHILIP: Richtig. Und wir schreiben jetzt "halal" drauf
und dann
>> SALLY: Ja, genau.
>> PHILIP: kann die jeder genießen.
>> SALLY: Und dann habt ihr aber auch einige
>> PHILIP: Genau.
>> SALLY: vegane und vegetarische.
>> PHILIP: Genau. Alle sauren Artikel sind eigentlich alle vegan.
Also so saure Drachenzungen.
>> SALLY: Ach, cool!
>> PHILIP: Genau.
Und Schnüre zum Beispiel sind veggie.
Weil die sind noch einmal so mit Bienenwachs umzogen.
>> SALLY: Super! Okay.
>> PHILIP: Aber ja...
Yo.
>> SALLY: Mein Klassiker aus den 90s
>> PHILIP: Ah!
>> SALLY: sind auf jeden Fall Ufos!
Und ich mag die blauen.
>> PHILIP: Genau,
die Ufos.
>> SALLY: Okay, komm!
>> PHILIP: Okay. los geht's!
Rein?
>> SALLY: Hier müssen wir jetzt
ein bisschen Volumen schaffen.
>> PHILIP: Hm.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Und jetzt packe ich
>> PHILIP: Ich meine, das ist doch Hammer, oder?
>> SALLY: das
so hier drunter.
>> PHILIP: Ach, schön! Ja.
Coole Idee!
>> SALLY: Und das hier.
>> PHILIP: Ja.
Superschön!
>> SALLY: Und dann kann man es
– ja, ich muss es nur noch richtig reinstecken.
>> PHILIP: Megaschön!
Okay, das war jetzt aber mal
>> SALLY: Voll die Kordel, oder?
wirklich die Eingebung, oder?
>> SALLY: Das soll jetzt gerade...
>> PHILIP: Mega! Superschön!
>> SALLY: So.
>> PHILIP: So. Wow!
>> SALLY: Unsere
>> PHILIP: Torte.
>> SALLY: explodierte Schultüte.
[Musik]
>> PHILIP: Hört sich gut an.
>> SALLY: Ja,
>> PHILIP: Und sieht auch gut aus!
>> SALLY: so richtig crunchy.
>> PHILIP: Was für eine Schultüte!
Wow!
>> SALLY: Oh!
>> PHILIP: Wow!
>> SALLY: Komm, wir probieren!
>> PHILIP: O mein Gott!
Okay, los geht's!
>> SALLY: Los!
Oh!
Jetzt habe ich voll das Kuchenstück weggenommen.
>> PHILIP: Boah!
>> SALLY: Ich bin
>> PHILIP: Krass!
gespannt.
Hast du Hitschies erwischt?
>> PHILIP: Hm. Aber ordentlich. Boah!
Merkst du es?
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SALLY & PHILIP: Boah!
>> PHILIP: Es kommt dieser Bubble-Gum-Flavour durch
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> PHILIP: und dann dieser Vanille
>> PHILIP: über die Creme.
Das ist boah!
Mmh!
>> SALLY: Das ist echt cool!
>> PHILIP: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Ich muss das noch mal machen
>> SALLY: Ich liebe ja Bubble-Gum-Geschmack,
>> PHILIP: Mmh!
>> SALLY: aber ich muss es noch mal machen
mit den sauren Hitschies.
>> PHILIP: Hm. Da wird das auch richtig cool.
>> SALLY: Hm.
Boah, echt cool!
>> PHILIP: Lecker, nicht?
>> SALLY: Und vor allem war die Torte gar nicht geplant.
>> SALLY: Mega!
>> PHILIP: Aber es ist witzig. Ich habe noch nie so Hitschies
in so einem Kuchen drinnen benutzt, also so klein,
so crushed.
>> SALLY: Das war vorhin. Die lagen da und dann...
>> PHILIP: Das ist megalecker!
Weil das gibt dem Kuchen noch so einen Biss irgendwie.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> PHILIP: Weil Kuchen geht ja sonst immer so...
>> SALLY: Man hat so Kaubonbonbiss
und die bleiben halt echt schön knackig.
>> PHILIP: Und das passt total zum Kuchen.
Das ist eine richtig coole Idee.
Ja. Also probieren!
>> SALLY: Probiert es aus.
Denkt an das Gewinnspiel.
>> PHILIP: Genau. Da kriegt ihr ganz viele
Bubble Gum Hitschies nach Hause, wenn ihr gewinnt.
>> SALLY: Genau, zehn Prozent Firmenanteile.
>> PHILIP: Ja, klar.
Tschüss!
Also wir bleiben
>> SALLY: Wir bleiben bei der Hitschie-Box.
>> PHILIP: beim Paket. Ja.
Also ja.
>> SALLY: Ja. Was will man schon damit,
>> PHILIP: Maybe one day.
>> SALLY: wenn man die Hitschie-Box haben kann?
>> PHILIP: Ja, Hammer.
>> SALLY: Also macht mit beim Gewinnspiel. Kommentiert.
>> PHILIP: Wir sind gespannt.
>> SALLY: Und viel Erfolg!
Ja, ich auch.
>> PHILIP: Gut.
>> SALLY: Hast du auch noch nie gemacht, nicht?
So einfach Zuschauer entscheiden lassen so:
>> PHILIP: Nee.
>> SALLY: "Entscheidet mal den Namen."
>> PHILIP: Aber die haben coole Ideen.
>> SALLY: Na klar!
>> PHILIP: Ja. Ich meine, die sind die Fans da draußen.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> PHILIP: Okay.
>> SALLY: Und backt die Einschulungstorte nach.
Bis zum nächsten Mal!
>> PHILIP: Tschü!
>> SALLY: Tschüss!
[Musik]